google sixth stage image capture teeth
your pixel 3rd and 3xl bulge colada on the
pixel 3
his anger the buddha customers the test
to the pixel 3rd javelin house and week
fit closing lid 3lcd evolution in
a gaming computers and video and euro so
the building model versus  between hel die
stiefel put pictures and bastards bad en
jotham in the solis times
right when starting off for the selfie
week in china tiel extremely similar the
natural beauty face module section i left
on to the pixel free but i would very
similar the absolute without to  buy now en
so free weekend level i see the
difference inzoom en de white balance
looks really big turn on each file dat
fabric 3 scratched as a house or wider lens with
for groups selfies bytes of
philips aan willoughby wire and who also
notice that
the first  year is a robot better on
this line 6 wel week en si lesson on the sky
blue well here are photo using the
weather lens and wanting the week an
absolute once again the white  balance is
final and luxe ruby nice warm to the l
d 3 and we craps lizzie that the pixel
3 a lux et le beam ever something very
pecific oil in that wall t-line in th
app onvif the page which is very inter
sting nou in this photo  is xlii
exact opposite the pixel 3 action looks
more detailed angry in the gate ground in
the background in so micro chauffer
flower delivery similar but the white
balance silver big difference in the
focal points are legion is called the chicken
type ria focused on the white flowers
wise the pizza 3rd focused burners and there
analytics creamy similar and so is a
giovanni sansai sieve river crab all over
europe
looks like the pixel 3 is a live demo
the something held in all part trys all the
details in the frieze in the bar land use
the  sea the biggest also is the pixel 3e ox
ey crops and two times set p
ey 5 times using port grimaud and you c
n easily bulls jeff and censorship very
olo describe the difference and white
balance the lid tril  ux en libie
marlou and the trilux
call de mar warm and absolutely and will be
made it like it's definitely liking
contras computers this kind of 3rd
lucy de cm x iping in the sport driver
on the pixel three boxes
the vvd sp civil process water however
the lid 3rd  house alarm ear nose and the
face respond for posted at i-signal
adler eksept the pixel 3 i'm going to
breed from what the pixels 3 grasses
need here take your finance lease
the nightside feature boltons extremely
similar exact pixel trilux and [ __ ] bit
more bright
and above  brake pad extreme researcher idea
and in this night site photo that nice
x-files semler exact title 3 is a
ruben never anything very thin background
both phones if we do a real le
diable photo it's really hard the whole
different but if you we chose you can
see that the white balance is a little
bit different
the pixel 3 is mark cool what the pixel 3rd
is al ahmar war
yes movieland the selfie video farmer
consult x film die semler eksept the
bicycle of  3rd
clear allah my the computer the pixel
3a that my aveling specific are
down this clip using network camera
balconies look extreme the similar the
might be a little different thin white
balance for all baha
de almost identical in is the same story
for this clip as well  and finally
finishing up with slow motion crook us
also x creamy similar so oil agents and
white balance
we had after that fun they become
conclusions weekend rifle is test the
pixel 3rd percent showtimes importer
mode in sharepoint pff guys who also
known as en  lakoff contras a short
fashion to the pixel 360 game is flash
3rd so if a narrow also in white
balance between all the sponge british
hermès
samsung phone can be cooler and those
others that warmer and acoustic
picture point on a frontside
where the pixel 3 kids a  extra lens for
wide selfies but the path of 3 j's
freshair selfie lens is a turbo rider
than the one to the pixel 3
in on a boat phones 2 for the moo  nshine
pinnacle photos both really impressive
the pizza 3e npo 3 etle
sorry jelly recommender photos warsaw
microphone is in ass irma on a
budget
if you enjoy this video major igt
subscribe to the bar and mix color
checker all those videos right there
thankyou machine will see you  in the
next video
[Music]